dancing in roller skates Razzie Awards
and appropriating people's cultures
these actors never fully recovered from
these box office in critical flops
Meg Ryan carved out a reputation as the
queen of rom-coms in the 90s but her
squeaky clean image and her career in
the movies took a huge blow at the turn
of the Millennium her marriage to Dennis
Quaid was on the rocks and when Sparks
flew between Ryan and her Proof of Life
co-star Russell Crowe it was the final
nail in the coffin the hostage Thriller
was panned by the majority of critics
but it was Ryan's real-life fling with
crow that ultimately derailed the
farmer's career when Ryan spoke to the
New York Times in 2019 she admitted that
the Fallout from proof of life and her
affair with Crow was a big turning point
for her career-wise saying I felt the
effect like I was the bad guy
when 2003's in the cut also bombed the
industry seemed to turn its back on Ryan
altogether she added the feeling with
Hollywood was Mutual I felt done when
they felt done probably
full formula everybody's a suspect
Jamie Kennedy was best known for playing
horror movie fanatic Randy Meeks in the
Scream movies until his ill-fated turn
as Tim Avery in 2005's Son of the Mask
the sequel put an end to his chances of
becoming the new Jim Carrey and
seriously derailed his career in
Hollywood the backlash had such an
effect on him that he made the 2007
documentary Heckler which was about the
destructive power of movie blogs a
relatively new medium at the time
Kennedy told IFC
my whole thing is review the piece not
the person if I make a movie about a
baby that flies and turns green that's
one thing but don't start attacking me
my family my life and my faith
personally
Heckler argues that there is no
accountability when it comes to film
reviews something that bothers Kennedy
greatly he said how come I'm not getting
an offer your career starts going and
you're like am I really a piece of it
just breeds Insanity some critics
enjoyed Heckler but just as many
couldn't get past the idea that it was
Kennedy's way of lashing out at those
who hated Son of the Mask
Akira toriyama's Dragon Ball remains one
of the most adored manga series ever
spawning several anime adaptations on
its way to becoming one of the highest
grossing media franchises of all time
the Animated Series Dragon Ball Z
arrived in America in the mid 90s and
while it took some time to catch on it
eventually found a home on Cartoon
Network from there it became a pop
culture phenomenon manga scholar Jason
Thompson told CBR it pushed the limits
of violence that you could show in a
kids series and it presented this very
visceral very original superhero power
Fantasy by the time Fox purchased the
movie rights the Dragon Ball fan base
was huge sadly the big screen adaptation
proved to be one of many anime remakes
that Hollywood would botch entirely
Justin chadwin seemed poised to become a
star after appearing as Tom Cruise's
Moody son and Steven Spielberg's War of
the Worlds but fans absolutely hated him
as Goku and not just because he was a
white guy guy playing an Asian character
social undergrounds Jeff Sorensen said
the film version was an emotionless boar
he wasn't alone in his opinion Dragon
Ball Evolution was received so poorly
that screenwriter Ben Ramsey apologized
to fans admitting that he was chasing a
big payday when he took on the project
although Chatwin had a popular recurring
role on Shameless he hasn't made an
impact on the big screen since
Believe It or Not Dragon Ball Evolution
wasn't the worst movie of 2009 according
to Rotten Tomatoes that unenviable title
went to Street Fighter the Legend of jun
Lee another ill-fated film based on a
Japanese property the first sign that
something was amiss was the fact that
the movie wasn't screened for critics in
advance of its release word of just how
bad Street Fighter the Legend of Chun Li
was soon spread however it reportedly
cost 50 million dollars to make but only
managed to pull in 8.7 million dollars
in the United States and around half
that amount at the worldwide box office
Kristen Krug had been in bad movies
before but she made them while playing
Lana Lang in Smallville in a gross error
of judgment Kruk left the long-running
Superman show to play Chun Li because
the schedule wouldn't allow her to do
both she told Metro at the time I just
wanted to try something else
like Kristen Krug Courtney Thorne smith
left a successful TV show to star in a
film that ended up sinking her career
the San francisco-born actor played
Alison Parker on Melrose Place for much
of the 90s but she grew tired of the fox
soap and tried to reinvent herself as a
movie star unfortunately for Thorne
smith her opposite number in 1998's
chairman of the board was none other
than Scott Carrot Top Thompson in 2018
to Mark its 20-year anniversary with a
rundown of just how bad the movie
actually was Yahoo movies shared their
disapproval the leading man takes the
brunt of the blame but Thorne smith also
comes in for some major criticism the
outlet wrote She sanks to carrot Top's
dismal level by donning a Native
American headdress seriously and then
burping the entire alphabet seriously
in a now Infamous episode of Late Night
with Conan O'Brien Norm Macdonald made
sure that nobody went to see chairman of
the board Thorne smith was on the show
to promote the movie but her fellow
guests couldn't help but poke fun
if it's got Carrot Top then you know
what a good name for it'd be what's that
Norm box office poison
turns out McDonald was right chairman of
the board only made 181
233 dollars
Pamela Anderson was seemingly destined
for fame the Canadian model turned
actress was the first baby born on
Canada's 100 year anniversary as a
nation Pamela made her first film
appearance while still in high school in
the erotic Thriller Crimes of Passion by
October 89 she was on the cover of
Playboy magazine she moved to LA to
pursue modeling and started booking
acting gigs the following year
Anderson's Lisa became a recurring
character on Home Improvement which led
to her Casting as CJ Parker in Baywatch
a show that made her a household name
Anderson attempted to make the leap to
movie star in the mid 90s but the campy
comic book adaptation barbed wire failed
miserably when she spoke to interview
magazine in 2016 Anderson blamed Studio
intervention it wasn't supposed to turn
out like it did they changed the script
six million times in the space of just a
few years Italian filmmaker Roberto
benini went from winning best actor at
the Academy Awards the starring in a
film so bad that it has a zero percent
rating on Rotten Tomatoes one of the 10
worst reviewed films in the history of
the website 1997's Life is Beautiful
which benini wrote directed and starred
in is a deeply affecting movie about a
Jewish father and his child who are
thrown into a Nazi concentration camp
during the height of World War II it was
worthy of all the praise just as 2002's
Pinocchio deserved the derision it
received benini was named worst actor at
the 2003 golden raspberry awards for his
work on finocchio cementing his Fall
From Grace The Fallout from Jake Lloyd's
appearance as Anakin Skywalker and Star
Wars Episode 1 The Phantom Menace is
well documented but it stands as one of
the swiftest and most unpleasant Falls
from Gray's experienced by any actor
just 10 years old at the time of the
film's release in 1999. Lloyd's
performance seemed to shoulder the brunt
of negative reaction to the film despite
this Mark Hamill defended the young
actor by explaining the vulture he did
exactly what George Lucas wanted him to
do online Venom from disappointed Star
Wars devotees combined with Relentless
off-camera bullying by other kids made
Lloyd's life and his words a living hell
he retired from acting in his pre-teens
and struggled with mental health issues
including paranoid schizophrenia in 2015
he was taken to a psychiatric facility
after leading police officers in a
Pursuit that resulted in a slew of
charges including reckless driving and
driving without a license his mother
Lisa Lloyd issued a statement to geek
news now in 2018 that her son was living
closer to his family who were quote all
working hard to help him if you or
someone you know is struggling with
mental health please contact the crisis
text line by texting home
741-741 or call the National Alliance on
Mental Illness helpline at
1-800-950-9
1-800-950-626 4 or visit the National
Institute of Mental Health Website
who is
to find the actor but the Lone Ranger
producer Jack rather took a tip from
Superman producers who attempt an
unknown named Christopher Reeve to play
the Man of Steel and hired a relative
newcomer named Clinton spilsberry to
play his lead spilsbury looked apart
with co-producer Martin starger telling
Entertainment Weekly he looked great in
The Mask unfortunately spillsberry
failed so miserably a delivering
dialogue that director William a fraker
brought an actor James Keach to dub all
of his lines what was it like
hell
sbury didn't do himself any favors by
flashing some serious movie star
attitude toward the cast and crew he
demanded that the film be shot in
sequence picked bites at local bars and
alleged an affair with the designer
Houston during an inebriated
face-to-face with Andy Warhol for
interview magazine the legend of the
Lone Ranger opened to scathing reviews
in 1981 and disastrous box office
returns
spilsbury bore the brunt of the negative
reaction earning two Razzie awards for
his debut film having traversed an arc
from Hollywood up and comer to never was
over the course of a single film
spilsberry retired from acting and
worked as a photographer according to
variety
actor Michael Beck gained Fame by
playing Gang leader Swan the hero of
Walter Hill's 1979 cult favorite the
Warriors but Beck had little time to
gain any career traction from that
film's success shortly after Warriors
producer Lawrence Gordon tapped back to
play the male lead in his next picture a
big budget fantasy musical built around
pop star Olivia Newton-John while the
resulting film Xanadu was one of the
biggest box office disasters of 1980 it
left the careers of most of its
principal cast and crew intact except
for Beck as he told Starburst magazine I
did say probably somewhere in the early
80s that the Warriors opened the door
for me and Xanadu slammed it shut Beck
found himself in a string of atrocious
action films including the certifiably
ridiculous Megaforce before returning to
television in the mid-1980s there he
found more substantive work through TV
movies such as Wes Craven's Chiller and
Douglas hickox's blackout he also forged
the second successful career as an
audiobook narrator for authors like John
Grisham and Michael Conley and in 2005
it reprized the role of swan in a video
game adaptation of the Warriors
After Earth was in abysmal box office in
critical failure
and what was worse was that Jaden took
the hit the son of actors Will Smith and
Jada Pinkett Smith Jaden Smith carved a
diverse career path at an early age
through music and acting that often
resembled his father's Hollywood
trajectory his initial efforts in both
mediums were successful Jaden moved from
a minor supporting role opposite his
father in The Pursuit of Happiness to a
lead role in the 2010 version of The
Karate Kid he also scored a top 10 hit
with the Justin Bieber collaboration
Never Say Never much of this progress
however was undone by 2013's After Earth
which again teamed Will and Jaden Smith
as co-stars M Night shyamalan's science
fiction epic about a father and son who
returned to an uninhabited Earth
thousands of years in the future was
co-produced by Will Smith but his star
power and a vast marketing budget
couldn't save the film from a tidal wave
of critical Venom much of which was
leveled at Jaden's lackluster
performance Jaden rebounded with the
2018 Indie flicks gate kitchen and a
supporting role in baz lerman's
short-lived hip-hop drama series The get
down but aside from that he has largely
kept his distance from acting safer
occasional voice over work for animated
projects like Intergalactic instead he
is focusing on music and other Pursuits
think you're overreacting Miss Crawford
and I think you're underreacting Mrs
Chadwick Faye Dunaway was a three-time
Oscar nominee a six-time Golden Globe
nominee and a major box office star when
she signed on to play screen Legend Joan
Crawford in the 1981 biopic Mommy
Dearest the film based on the
autobiography of Crawford's daughter
Christina painted a particularly
unflattering portrait of the actress as
a manipulative and abusive figure a
portrayal that Dunaway played at
Hurricane level intensity in volume
though Dunaway landed best actress
nominations from The National Society of
film critics and New York Film critics
Circle for her performance most critics
Savaged the film audiences seem to
regard Mommy Dearest as high camp which
Paramount acknowledged by revising its
promotional campaign with the tagline
meet the biggest mother of them all
for Dunaway the negative publicity had a
damaging effect on her career she found
herself mired in dismal flops or
underperforming dramas though her turn
as an unglamorous alcoholic and Barfly
won her a Golden Globe nomination
television offered her more substantive
work and she earned an Emmy for a 1994
episode of Colombo as well as a Golden
Globe for the HBO drama Gia
Dunaway rarely spoke about Mommy Dearest
but she did tell people in 2016. I think
it turned my career in a direction where
people would irretrievably have the
wrong impression of me and that's an
awful thing to beat
hang on
for a brief period of time in the 90s
actor Skeet Ulrich was poised to become
a major Hollywood star he had a string
of modest hits including the craft
peeking with his appearance as Billy
Loomis and Wes Craven's Scream the
success of that film suggested Ulrich
would follow in the path of actors like
Johnny Depp to whom he was frequently
compared but unfortunately the scream
bump amounted to nothing after a minor
role in James L Brooks is as good as it
gets
Ulrich appeared in a series of critical
and box office flops including Richard
linklater's the Newton Boys Paul
Schroeder's adaptation of Elmore
Leonard's touch and Ang Lee's Ride With
the Devil but it was the 2000 Thriller
track down that appeared to deliver the
death blow to ulrix's film career
lawsuits over plagiarism issues delayed
the film's release until 2004. and it
debuted on home video to resounding
dismissal by critics
Ulrich made the move to television where
he found modest success on Riverdale and
the cult favorite series Jericho more
recently he replies role as Billy Loomis
in 2022's Scream and 2023's scream 6
appearing in Visions to his daughter
having enjoyed success as both a
stand-up comedian and actor Nick
Swardson joined forces with Adam Sandler
to try his hand at a feature film career
to build up the swordson's movie starred
and was gradual with assignments as a
writer and bit player on Grandma's Boy
and in several Sandler titles but by
2011 the powers that be decided swartson
was ready for his time in the spotlight
with the aptly titled Bucky Larson born
to be a star as the vehicle to Usher him
into the big time unfortunately while
Bucky Larson attained stardom of A Sort
as an adult film actor the film did not
Grant swartson access to the A-list
critics unsheathed their claws for the
film audiences seem to agree delivering
only 2.5 million dollars in U.S ticket
sales swordson however did not and he
defended the film in a 2011 interview
with splitsider during the interview he
said that the negative response from
critics quote makes them look like such
morons he has since returned to the
steady rotation in Sandler films and he
has found some Redemption on television
as a voice actor guest star and content
creator
no single picture sent Jean-Claude Van
Damme tumbling from the top of the
action movie Heap in the late 80s and
1990s it was the result of a string of
them his box office fortunes declined
slowly but steadily after back-to-back
hits with timecop and Street Fighter in
1994. mid 90s titles like sudden death
and maximum risk weren't failures both
surpassed their budgets but failed to
bring in time cup sized windfalls
critics like to point to his twin
collaborations with Hong Kong director
hark Choi 1997's double team a 1998's
knockoff as the beginning of the end for
Jean-Claude Van Damme again both made a
profit but both films relied on
increasingly outlandish storylines and
laughable pair ups for Van Damme Dennis
Rodman and Mickey Rourke in double team
and Rob Schneider and knockoff if Van
Damme's Fall From Grace can be
attributed to anyone movie though it's
probably an unnecessary sequel to
universal Soldier
1999's universal Soldier the return
which pitted Van Damme's former super
soldier against the next generation of
enhanced combatants Michael Jai White
who appeared in the first film turns up
as the new bad unisol the movie grossed
about 10 million dollars in ticket sales
against a 45 million dollar budget Van
Damme had already dipped a toe into
direct to video Waters with 1998's
Legionnaire but after universal Soldier
the return He waited fully into those
Waters and remained there until his
career resurged with jcbd and The
Expendables 2. the improbable movie
stardom of comedian Paulie Shore reached
its Zenith with 1996's biodome a film
with the unique distinction of holding a
Metascore of one which is characterized
as overwhelming dislike on Metacritic
the film was not a financial plot
earning 13.4 million dollars against an
8.5 million dollar production budget but
it was Far Below receipts for his
previous efforts the modest return
combined with brutal critical response
seemed to indicate that the worm had
turned on Shore's film career this was
cemented by the fact that 1997's the
curse of Inferno skipped the theatrical
release altogether and debuted on the
movie channel Shore continues to appear
in films though primarily as a
supporting player or voice-over actor in
English dubs of international animated
films the response to his 2003
mockumentary Paulie Shore is dead was
more sympathetic though it also failed
to make an impact at the box office
foreign
[Music]